If you're a fan of pedantic or data classes, you'll definitely be interested in this episode.
We are talking about a super fast data modeling and validation framework called msgspec.
And some of the types in here might even be better for general purpose use than Python's
native classes. Join me and Jim Chris Hariff to talk about his framework msgspec.
This is Talk Python to Me, episode 442, recorded November 2nd, 2023.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python. This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the podcast using @talkpython.
Both on mastodon.org. Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes
at talkpython.fm. We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified about upcoming shows and be
part of that episode.
This episode is sponsored by Posit Connect from the makers of Shiny. Publish, share,
and deploy all of your data projects that you're creating using Python. Streamlit, Dash,
Shiny, Bokeh, FastAPI, Flask, Reports, Dashboards, and APIs. Posit Connect supports all of them.
Try Posit Connect for free by going to talkpython.fm/posit. P-O-S-I-T. And it's brought to you by us over
at Talk Python Training. Did you know that we have over 250 hours of Python courses?
Yeah, that's right. Check them out at talkpython.fm/courses. Jim.
Hello.
Welcome to Talk Python. I mean, it's awesome to have you here.
Yeah. Thanks for having me.
Yeah, of course. I spoke to the Litestar guys, you know, at lightstar.dev and had them
on the show. And I was talking about their DTOs, different types of objects they can
pass around in their APIs and their web apps. And like FastAPI, they've got this concept
where you kind of bind a type, like a class or something to an input to a web API. And
it does all that sort of magic like FastAPI. And I said, Oh, so you guys probably work
with PyData. It's like, yes, but let me tell you about msgspec. Because that's where
the action is. They were so enamored with your project that I just had to reach out
and have you on. It looks super cool. I think people are going to really enjoy learning
about it.
Yeah, thanks. Yeah. It's nice to hear that.
Yeah. We're going to dive into the details. It's going to be a lot of fun. Before we get
to them, though, give us just a quick introduction on who you are. So people, you know, people
don't know you yet.
So my name's Jim Christreif. I am currently an engineering manager doing actually mostly
dev work at Voltron Data, working on the IBIS project, which is a completely different conversation
than what we're going to have today. Prior to that, I've worked on a couple of startups
and was most of them doing Dask, was the main thing I've contributed to in the past on an
open source Python front. For those not aware, Dask is a distributed compute ecosystem. I
come from the PyData side of the Python ecosystem, not the web dev side.
Nice. Yeah, I've had Matthew Rocklin on a couple of times, but it's been a while, so
people don't necessarily know, but it's like super distributed pandas, kind of. Grid computing
for pandas, sort of.
Or say like Spark written in Python.
Sure. You know, another thing that's been on kind of on my radar, but I didn't really
necessarily realize it was associated with you. Tell people just a bit about IBIS. Like
IBIS is looking pretty interesting.
IBIS is, I don't want to say the wrong thing. IBIS is a portable data frame library is the
current tagline we're using. If you're coming from R, it's dplyr for Python. It's more than
that and it's not exactly that, but that's a quick mental model. So you write data frame
like code. We're not pandas compatible. We're pandas like enough that you might find something
extra familiar and it can compile down to, you know, generate SQL for 18 plus different
database backends. Also like PySpark and a couple other things.
Okay.
So you write your code once and you kind of run it on whatever.
I see. And you do pandas like things, but it converts those into database queries. Is
that right?
Yeah. Yeah. So it's a data frame API. It's not pandas compatible, but if you're familiar
with pandas, you should be able to pick it up. You know, we cleaned up what we thought
as a bunch of rough edges with the pandas API.
Yeah. Were those pandas one or pandas two rough edges?
Both. It's, I don't know. It's pandas like.
Sure. Yeah. This looks really cool. That's a topic for another day, but awesome. People
can check that out. But this time you're here to talk about your personal project, msgspec.
Am I saying that right? Are you saying MSG or msgspec?
msgspec.
Right on. I think a lot of these projects sometimes need a little, like, here's the
MP3 you can press play on, like how it's meant to be said, you know? And sometimes it's kind
of obvious like PyPI versus PyPi. Other times it's just like, okay, I know you have a really
clever name.
People say numpy.
Yes, I know. People say numpy all the time. I'm like, I don't want to, I try to not correct
guess cause it's, it's not kind, but I also feel awkward. They will say numpy and I'll
say, how do you feel about numpy? They're like, numpy's great. I'm like, okay, we're
just going back and forth like this for the next hour. It's fine. But yeah, it's, it's
always, I think some of these could use a little, like a little play on. So msgspec,
tell people about what it is.
Yeah. So gone through a couple of different taglines. The current one is a fast serialization
and validation library with a built-in support for JSON, MessagePack, YAML, and TOML. If
you are familiar with Pydantic, that's probably one of the closest, you know, most popular
libraries that does a similar thing. You define kind of a structure of your data using type
annotations and msgspec will parse your data to ensure it is that structure and does
so efficiently. It's also compatible with a lot of the other serialization libraries.
You could also use it as a stand in for JSON, you know, with the JSON dumps, JSON loads,
you don't need to specify the types.
Right. It's, I think the mental model of kind of like it swims in the same water, the same
pond as Pydantic, but it's also fairly distinguished from Pydantic, right? As we're going to explore
throughout our chat here.
The goal from my side, one of the goals was to replicate more of the experience writing
Rust or Go with Rust Serde or Go's JSON, where the serializer kind of stands in the background
rather than my experience working with Pydantic where it felt like the base model kind of
stood at the foreground. You're defining the models, serialization kind of comes onto the
types you've defined, but you're not actually working with the serializers on the types
themselves.
Got it. So an example, let me see if I, see if I do have it. An example might be if I
want to take some message I got from some response I got from an API, I want to turn
it into a Pydantic model or I'm writing an API. I want to take something from a client,
whatever. I'll go and create a Pydantic class. And then I, the way I use it is I go to that
class and I'll say star star dictionary I got. And then it comes to life like that,
right? Where there's a little more focused on just the, the serialization and has this
capability. But like, like you said, it's optional in the sense.
Yeah. I, in message spec, all types are on equal footing. So we use functions, not methods,
because if you want to decode into a list of ints, I can't add a method to a list. You
know, it's a Python built in type. So you'd say msgspec dot JSON dot decode your
message. And then you'd specify the type annotation as part of that function call. So it could
be, you know, list bracket int.
Right. So you'll say decode. And then you might say type equals list of, of your type
or like you say, list of int. And that's hard when you have to have a class that knows how
to basically become what the model, the data passed in is, even if it's just a list, some
Pydantic classes, you got to kind of jump through some hoops to say, Hey, Pydantic,
I don't have a thing to give you. I want a list of those things. And that's the top level
thing is, you know, bracket bracket. It's not, it's not any one thing I can specify
in Python easily.
Yeah. To, to be fair to the Pydantic project, I believe in V2, the type adapter object can
work with that, but that is, you know, it's a, it's a different way of working with it.
I wanted to have one API that did it all.
Sure. And it's awesome. They made it. I mean, I want to put this out front, like I'm a massive
fan of Pydantic. What Samuel's done there is incredible. And it's just, it's really
made a big difference in the way that people work with data in Python. It's awesome. But
it's also awesome that you have this project that is an alternative and it makes different
assumptions and you can see those really play out in like the performance or the APIs. So
you know, like Pydantic encourages you to take your classes and then send them the data,
but you've kind of got to know like, oh, there's this type adapter thing that I can give a
list of my class and then make it work. Right. But it's not just, oh, you just fall into
that by trying to play with the API, you know?
Yeah. Yeah. And I think having, being able to specify any type means we, we work with
standard library data classes, the same as we work with our, our built-in struct type
or we also work with the adders types. You know, everything is kind of on equal footing.
Yeah. And I, what I want to really dig into is your custom struct type that has some really
cool properties, not class properties, but components, features of the class of the type
there. Yeah. Let's look at a couple of things here. So as you said, it's a fast and I love
how somehow italicies on the word fast makes it feel even faster. Like it's leaning forward,
you know, it's leaning into the speed, a faster realization and validation library. The validation
is kind of can be, but not required, right? The types can be, but they don't have to be.
So I think that's one of the ways that really differs from Pydantic. But the other is Pydantic
is quite focused on JSON, whereas this is JSON, MessagePack, YAML, and TOML. Everyone
knows what JSON is. I always thought of TOML as kind of like, like YAML or are they really
different?
It's another configuration focused language. I think people, some people do JSON for config
files, but I personally don't like to handwrite JSON. YAML and TOML are like more human friendly
in quotes forms of that. YAML is a superset of JSON. TOML is its own thing. And then MessagePack
is a binary JSON like file format.
Yeah. MessagePack. I don't know how many people work with that. Like where would people run
into MessagePack if they were like say consuming an API or what API framework would people
be generating MessagePack in Python typically?
That's a good question. So going back to the creation of this project, actually, msgspec
sounds a lot like MessagePack. And that was intentional because that's what I wrote it
for originally. So as I said at the beginning, I'm one of the original contributors to Dask,
worked on Dask for forever. And the Dask distributed scheduler uses MessagePack for its RP serialization
layer that kind of fell out of what was available at the time. We benchmarked a bunch of different
libraries and that was the fastest way to send bytes between nodes in 2015.
Sure.
The distributed schedulers RPC framework has kind of grown haphazardly over time. And there
were a bunch of bugs due to some hacky things we were doing with it. And also it was a slower
than we would have wanted. So this was an attempt to write a faster MessagePack library
for Python that also did fancier things, supported more types, did some schema validation because
like we wanted to catch the worker is sending this data and the scheduler is getting it
and saying it's wrong. And we wanted to also add in a way to make schema evolution, meaning
that I can have different versions of my worker and scheduler and client process and things
kind of work. If I add new features to the scheduler, they don't break the client. You
know, we have a nice forward and backward compatibility story. And so that's what kind
of fell out.
Yeah, it's a really nice feature. We're going to dive into that. But you know, you might
think, oh, well, just update your client or update the server. But there's all sorts of
situations that get really weird. Like if you have Redis as a caching layer and you
create a MessagePack object and stick it in there and then you deploy a new version of
the app, it could maybe can't deserialize anything in the cache anymore because it says
something's missing or something's there that it doesn't expect. Right. And so this evolution
is important there. If you got long running work and you stash it into a database and
you pull it back out, like all these things where it kind of lives a little outside the
process, all of a sudden it starts to matter that before you even consider like clients
that run separate code, right? Like you could be the client, just different places in time.
Yeah. Yeah. So adding a little bit more structure to how you define messages in a way to make
the scheduler more maintainable. That work never landed. It's as it is with open source
projects. It's a democracy and also a duocracy. And you know, you don't always have this can
be done at that ends. I still think it'll be valuable in the future. But some stuff
was changing the scheduler and a serialization is no longer the bottleneck that it was two
and a half years ago when this originally started.
So let me put this in context for people, maybe make it relevant. Like maybe right now
someone's got a FastAPI, API, and they're using Pydantic and obviously it generates
all the awesome JSON they want. Is there a way to, how would you go about creating say
a Python server-based system set of APIs that maybe as an option take MessagePack or maybe
use that as a primary way? Like it could be maybe, you know, passing an accept header.
To take MessagePack?
If you want to exchange MessagePack client server Python right now, what do you do?
That's a good question. To be clear, I am not a web dev. I do not do this for a living.
I think there is no standard application slash MessagePack. I think people can use it if
they want, but that's not a, it's a standardized thing the same way that JSON is.
Yeah.
I think that Litestar as a framework does support this out of the box. I don't know
about FastAPI. I'm sure there's a way to hack it in as there is with any ASCII server.
Yeah. Litestar, like I said, I had Litestar on those guys maybe a month ago and yeah,
it was super, super cool about that. So yeah, I know that they support msgspec and
a lot of different options there, but you know, you could just, I imagine you could
just return binary bits between you and your client. I'm thinking of like latency sensitive
microservice type things sort of within your data center. How can you lower serialization,
deserialization, serialization, like all that, that cost that could be the max, you know,
the biggest part of what's making your app spend time and energy. Michael out there says
would love PyArrow parquet support for large data.
There's been a request for arrow integration with MessagePack. I'm not exactly sure what
that would look like. Arrow containers are pretty efficient on their own. Breaking them
out into a bunch of objects or stuff to work with MessagePack doesn't necessarily make
sense in my mind. But anyway, if you have ideas on that, please open an issue or comment
on the existing issue.
Yeah, indeed. All right. So let's see. Some of the highlights are high performance encoders
and decoders across those protocols we talked. You have benchmarks. We'll look at them for
in a minute. You have a really nice, a lot of support for different types that can go
in there that can be serialized, but there's also a way to extend it to say, I've got a
custom type that you don't think is serializable to whatever and thing, a MessagePack, JSON,
whatever. But I can write a little code that'll take it either way, you know, dates or something
that drive me crazy, but it could be like an object ID out of MongoDB or other things
that are seem like they should go back and forth, but don't, you know, right. So that's
really nice. And then zero cost schema validation, right? It validates decodes and validates
JSON two times as fast as ORJSON, which is one of the high performance JSON decoders.
And that's just decoding, right? And then the struct thing that we're going to talk
about, which the struct type is kind of what brings the parody with Pydantic, right?
Yeah. You could think of it as Pydantic's base model. It's our built in data class like
type. So structs are data class like, like everything in msgspec are implemented
fully as a C extension. Getting these to work required reading a lot of the CPython source
code because we're doing some things that I don't want to say that they're not, they
don't want you to do. We're not doing them wrong, but they're not really documented.
So for example, the, the, when you subclass for msgspec or msgspec.struct, that's
using a meta class mechanism, which is a way of defining types that define types. And the
meta class is written in C, which CPython doesn't make easy to do. So it's a C class
that creates new C types. They're pretty speedy. They are 10 to 100X faster for most operations
than even handwriting a class that does the same thing, but definitely more than data
classes or adders.
Yeah. It's super interesting. And I really want to dive into that. Like I almost can
see the struct type being relevant even outside of msgspec and in general potentially.
So yeah, we'll see about that, but it's super cool. And Michael also points out like he's
the one who made the issue. So sorry about that. He's commented already, I suppose in
a sense, but yeah. Awesome. Cool. All right. So let's do this. I think probably the best
way to get started is we could talk through an example and there's a really nice article
by Itmar Turner-Trauring who's been on the show a couple of times called Faster, More
Memory Efficient Python, JSON Parsing with msgspec. And just has a couple of examples
that I thought maybe we could throw up and you could talk to, speak to your thoughts
of like, why is the API work this way? Here's the advantages and so on. Yeah. So there's
this big, I believe this is the GitHub API, just returning these giant blobs of stuff
about users. Okay. And it says, well, if we want to find out what users follow what repos
or how many, given a user, how many repos do they follow? Right. We could just say with
open, read this and then just do a JSON load and then do the standard dictionary stuff,
right? Like for everything, we're going to go, go to the element that we got out and
say bracket some key, bracket some key. You know, it looks like key not found errors are
just lurking in here all over the place, but you know, it's, you should know that maybe
it'll work right. If you know the API, I guess. So it was like, this is the standard way.
How much memory does this use? How much time does it take? Look, we can basically swap
out or JSON. I'm not super familiar with or JSON. Are you? Yeah. Or JSON is compatible
ish with the standard lib JSON, except that it returns bytes rather than strengths. Got
it. Okay. There's also iJSON, I believe, which makes it streaming. So there's that. And then
it says, okay, well, how would this look if we're going to use msgspec? And in his
example, he's using structured data. So the structs, this is like the Pydantic version,
but it doesn't have to be this way, but it is this way, right? This is the one he chose.
So maybe just talk us through, like, how would you solve this problem using msgspec and
classes? Yeah. So as he's done here in this blog post, he's defined a couple of struct
types for the various levels of this message. So repos, actors, and interactions, and then
parses the message directly into those types. So the final call there is passing in the
read message and then specifying the type as a list of interactions, which are tree
down into actors and repos. Exactly. So this is what you mentioned earlier about having
more function-based. So you just say decode, give it the string or the bytes, and you say
type equals list of bracket, up-level class. And just like Pydantic, these can be nested.
So there's an interaction, which has an actor. There's an actor class, which has a login,
which has a type. So your Pydantic Mendel model for how those kind of fit together is
pretty straightforward, right? Pretty similar. Yeah. And then you're just programming with
classes. Awesome. Yep. And it'll all work well with like mypy or PyWrite or whatever
you're using if you're doing static analysis tools. Yeah. So you've thought about making
sure that not just does it work well from a usability perspective, but it like the type
checkers don't go crazy. Yeah. And any, you know, editor integration you have should just
work. Nice. Because there's sometimes, oh gosh, I think maybe FastAPI has changed this,
but you'll have things like you would say the type of an argument being passed in, if
it's say coming off the query string, you would say it's depend. It's a type depends,
not a, not an int, for example. It's because it's being pulled out of the query string.
I think that's FastAPI. And while it makes the runtime happy and the runtime says, oh,
I see you want to get this int from the query string, the type checkers and stuff are like,
depends. What is this? Like, this is an int. Why are you trying to use this depends as
an int? This doesn't make any sense. I think it's a bit of a challenge to have the runtime,
the types drive the runtime, but still not freak it out. You know? Yeah. I think that
the Python typing ecosystem, especially with the recent changes in new versions and the
annotated wrapper are moving towards a system where these kinds of APIs can be spelled natively
in ways that the type checkers will understand. Right. But if you're a product that existed
before these changes, you obviously had some preexisting way to make those work that might
not play as nicely. So there's, there's the upgrade cost of the project. I'm not envious
of the work that Samuel Covenant team have had to do to upgrade Pydantic to erase some
old warts in the API that they found. It's nice to see what they've done and it's, it's
impressive, but it's, I have the benefit of starting this project after those changes
in typing system existed, you know, can look at hindsight mistakes others have made and
learn from them.
Yeah, that's really excellent. They have done, like I said, I'm a big fan of Pydantic and
it took them almost a year. I interviewed Samuel about that change and it was no joke.
You know, it was a lot of work, but you know what they came up with pretty compatible,
pretty, pretty much feels like the same Pydantic, but you know, if you peel back the covers,
it's definitely not. All right. So the other interesting thing about it, Inmar's article
here is the performance sides is okay. Do you get fixed memory usage or does it vary
based on the size of the data and do you get schema validation? Right. So standard lib,
straight JSON module, 420 milliseconds. OR JSON, the fast one, a little less than twice
as fast, 280 milliseconds. IJSON for iterable JSON, 300. So a little more than the fast
one. Message spec, 90 milliseconds. That's awesome. That's like three times as fast as
the better one over four times as fast as the built-in one.
It also is doing, you know, quote unquote more work. It's a validating the responses
it comes in.
Exactly.
So you're sure that it's correct then too.
Yeah. And all those other ones are just giving you dictionaries and YOLO, do what you want
with them. Right. But here you're actually all those types that you described, right?
The interaction and the actors and the repos and the class structure, that's all validation.
So, and on top of that, you've created classes, which are heavier weight than dictionaries
because general classes are heavier weight than dictionaries because they have the dunder
dict that has all the fields in there effectively anyway. Right?
That's not true for, for structs. Structs are slot classes.
Yes. Structs.
They are lighter weight to allocate than a dictionary or a standard class. That's one
of the reasons they're faster.
Yeah. Structs are awesome. And so the other thing I was pointing out is, you know, you've
got 40 megabytes of memory usage versus 130. So almost four times less than the standard
module. And the only thing that beats you is the iterative one, because it literally
only has one in memory at a time. Right. One element. Yeah.
So, so this benchmark is kind of hiding two things together. So there, there is the output,
what you're parsing. Everything here except for IJSON is going to parse the full input
into something.
One big batch.
Message spec is more efficient than orJSON or the standard lib in this respect, because
we're only extracting the fields we care about, but you're still going to end up with a list
of a bunch of objects. IJSON is only going to pull one into memory at a time. So it's
going to have less in memory there. And then you have the, the memory usage of the parsers
themselves, which can also vary. So orJSON's memory or usage in its parser is a lot higher
than message specs, regardless of the output size. There's a little more internal state.
So this is a pretty interesting distinction that you're calling out here. So for example,
if people check out this article, which I'll link, there's like tons of stuff that people
don't care about in the JSON, like the avatar URL, the gravatar ID, you know, the reference
type, whether it's a brand, like this stuff that you just don't care about. Right. But
the parser then you got to read that. But what's pretty cool. You're saying is like,
in this case, the class that it Mark came up with is just repo driving from struct.
It just has name. There's a bunch of other stuff in there, but you don't care about it.
And so what you're saying is like, if you say that that's the decoder, it looks at that
and goes, there's a bunch of stuff here. We're not loading that. We're just going to look
for the things you've explicitly asked us to model. Right. That's all.
There's no sense in doing the work if you're never going to look at it.
A lot of different serialization frameworks. Can't remember how Pydantic responds when
you do this, but you know, the comments beyond Pydantic, so it doesn't really matter is they'll
freak out to say, Oh, there's extra stuff here. What am I supposed, you know, for example,
this repo, it just has name, but in the data model, it has way more in the, the JSON data.
So you try to deserialize it. I'll go, well, I don't have room to put all this other stuff.
Things are, you know, freak out. And this one is just like, no, we're just going to
filter down to what you asked for. I really, it's nice in a couple of ways. It's nice from
performance, nice from clean code. I don't have to put all those other fields I don't
care about, but also from, you talked about the evolution friendliness, right? Because
what's way more common is that things get added rather than taken away or change. It's
like, well, the complexity grows. Now repos also have this, you know, related repos or
sub repos or whatever the heck they have. Right. And this model here will just let you
go, whatever. Don't care.
Yeah. If GitHub updates their API and adds new fields, you're not going to get an error.
And if they remove a field, you should get a nice error that says expected, you know,
field name, and now it's missing. You can track that down a lot easier than a random
key error.
I agree. I think, okay, let's, let's dive into the struct a little bit because that's
where we're kind of on that now. And I think this is one of the highlights of what you
built again. It's kind of the same mental model as people are familiar with some data
classes with Pytantic and Adders and so on. So when I saw your numbers, I won't come back
and talk about benchmarks with numbers on, but I just saw like, wow, this is fast. And
now the memory usage is low. You must be doing something native. You must be doing something
crazy in here. That's not just Dunder slots. While Dunder slots is awesome. It's there's
more to it than that. Right. And so the written NC quite speedy and lightweight. So measurably
faster than data classes, Adders and Pytantic. Like tell us about these classes. Like this
is, this is pretty interesting.
As mentioned earlier, they're not exactly, but they're, they're basically slots classes.
So Python data model actually CPython's data model is either a class is a standard class
where it stores its attributes in a dict. That's not exactly true. There's been some
optimizations where the keys are stored separately alongside the class structure and all of the
values are stored on the object instances. But in model, there's dict classes and there's
slots classes, which you pre-declare your attributes to be in this, this Dunder slots
iterable. And those get stored in line in the same allocation as the object instance.
There's no pointer chasing. What that means is that you can't set extra attributes on
them that weren't pre-declared, but also things are a little bit more efficient. We create
those automatically when you subclass from a struct type. And we do a bunch of other
interesting things that are stored on the type. That is why we had to write a meta class
and see.
I went to read it. I'm like, whoa, okay. Well, maybe we'll come back to this. There's a lot
of stuff going on in that type.
This is one of the problems with this, this hobby projects is that I wrote this for fun
and a little bit of work related, but mostly fun. And it's not the easiest code base for
others to step in to. It fits my mental model. Not necessarily everyone's.
Yeah. I can tell you weren't looking for VC funding cause you didn't write it in Rust.
Seems to be the common denominator these days.
Yeah.
Why C just because the CPython's already in C and that's the
And I knew C. I do know Rust, but for what I wanted to do and the use case I had in mind,
I wanted to be able to touch the C API directly. And that felt like the easiest way to go about
doing it.
This portion of talk Python to me is brought to you by Posit, the makers of Shiny, formerly
R studio and especially shiny for Python. Let me ask you a question. Are you building
awesome things? Of course you are. You're a developer or a data scientist. That's what
we do. And you should check out Posit connect. Posit connect is a way for you to publish,
share and deploy all the data products that you're building using Python.
People ask me the same question all the time. Michael, I have some cool data science project
or notebook that I built. How do I share it with my users, stakeholders, teammates? Do
I need to learn FastAPI or flask or maybe view or react JS? Hold on now. Those are cool
technologies and I'm sure you'd benefit from them, but maybe stay focused on the data project.
Let Posit connect handle that side of things. With Posit connect, you can rapidly and securely
deploy the things you build in Python streamlet dash, shiny, Bokeh, FastAPI flask, quadro
reports, dashboards and API's. Posit connect supports all of them. And Posit connect comes
with all the bells and whistles to satisfy it and other enterprise requirements. Make
deployment the easiest step in your workflow with Posit connect. For a limited time, you
can try Posit connect for free for three months by going to talkpython.fm/ Posit.
That's talkpython.fm/ P O S I T. The link is in your podcast player show notes.
Thank you to the team at Posit for supporting talk Python.
Okay. So from a consumer of this struct class, I just say class, your examples, user is a
class user, parentheses, dress from struct in the field, colon type. So like name, colon
string groups, colon set of stir and so on. It looks like standard data classes type of
stuff. But what you're saying is your meta class goes through and looks at that and says,
okay, we're going to create a class called user, but it's going to have slots called
name, email and groups among other things. Right. Like does that magic for us?
Yeah. And then it sets up a bunch of internal data structures that are stored on the type.
Okay. Like give me a sense of like, like what's, what's something, why, why do you got to put
that in there? What's in there?
So the way data classes work after they do all the type parsing stuff, which we have
to do too, they then generate some code and eval it to generate each of the model methods.
So when you're importing or when you define a new data class, it generates an init method
and evals it and then stores it on the instance. That means that you have little bits of byte
code floating around for all of your new methods. Message spec structs instead, each of the
standard methods that the implementation provides, which would be, you know, init, wrapper, equality
checks, copies, you know, various things are single C functions. And then the type has
some data structures on it that we can use to define those. So we have a single init
method for all struct types that's used everywhere. And as part of the init method, we need to
know the fields that are defined on the struct. So we have some data stored on there about
like the field names, default values, various things.
Nice.
Because they're written in C rather than, you know, Python byte code, they can be a
lot faster. And because we're not having to eval a new method every time we define a struct,
importing structs is a lot faster than data classes. Something I'm not going to guess,
I have to look up on my benchmarks, but they are basically as efficient to define as a
handwritten class where data classes have a bunch of overhead. If you've ever written
a project that has, you know, a hundred of them, importing can slow down.
Yeah. Okay. Because you basically are dynamically building them up, right? In data class story.
Yeah. So you've got kind of the data class stuff. You got, as you said, Dunder net, repper,
copy, et cetera. But you also have Dunder match args for pattern matching. That's pretty
cool. And Dunder rich repper for pretty printing support with rich. Yeah. If you just rich.print,
it'll take that, right? What happens then?
It pre-prints it similar to like how a data class should be rendered.
Rich is making a pretty big impact. So rich is special.
I enjoy using it.
This is excellent. You've got all this stuff generated. So much of it is in C and super
lightweight and fast. But from the way we think of it, it's just a Python class, even
little less weird than data classes, right? Because you don't have to put a decorator
on it. You just derive from, from this thing. So that's super cool. Yeah. Super neat.
The hope was that these would feel familiar enough to users coming from data classes or
adders or Pydantic or all the various models that learning a new one wouldn't be necessary.
They they're the same.
Excellent. One difference if you're coming from Pydantic is there is no method to define
done these by default. So you define a struct with fields, A, B, and C only A, B, and C
exists as attributes on that, that class. You don't have to worry about any conflicting
names.
Okay. So for example, like the Pydantic ones have, I can't remember the V1 versus V2. It's
like, I can't remember like two dictionary effectively, right? Where they'll like dump
out the JSON or strings or things like that.
In V1, there's a method dot JSON, which if you have a field name, JSON will conflict.
They are remedying that by adding a model prefix for everything, which I think is a
good idea. I think that's a good way of handling it.
Yeah. Yeah. It's like model underscore JSON or dict or something like that. Yeah. Cool.
Yeah. That's one of the few breaking changes. They actually, unless you're deep down in
the guts of Pydantic that you'll, you might encounter. Yeah. You don't have to worry about
that stuff because you're more function based, right? You would say decode or I guess, yeah,
decode here's some, some data, some JSON or something. And then the thing you decode it
into would be your user type. You'd say type equals user rather than go into the user directly.
Right. Can we put our own, own properties and methods and stuff on these classes and
that'll work all right?
Yeah. They, they, this to a user, you should think of this as a data class that doesn't
use a decorator. They should be identical unless you're ever trying to touch, you know,
the dunder data class fields attribute that exists on data classes. There should be no
runtime differences as far as you can tell.
And when you're doing the schema validation, it sounds like you're basically embracing
the optional optionality of, of the type system. If you say int, it has to be there. If you
say optional int or int pipe none, may or may not be there, right?
No, it's, it's, it's close. I'm going to be pedantic here a little bit. The optional fields
are ones that have default values set. So optional bracket int without a default is
still a required field. It's just one that could be an int or none. You'd have to have
a literal none passed in. Otherwise we'd error. This more matches with how mypy interprets
the type system.
Okay. So if I had an optional thing, but it had no value, it would have to explicitly
set it to none.
Yes.
Or would, yeah. Or it'd have to be there in the data every time. Like other things, you
have default factories, right? Passing a function that gets called if it does, I guess if it
doesn't exist, right? If the data's in there, it's being deserialized, it won't. Okay. Excellent.
And I guess your, your decorator creates the initializer. But another thing that I saw
that you had was you have this post init, which is really nice. Like a way to say like,
okay, it's been deserialized. Let me try a little further. Tell us about this. This is
cool.
Yeah. It's coming from data classes. They have the same method. So if you need to do
any extra thing after init, you can use it here rather than trying to override the built-in
init, which we don't let you do.
Right. Because it has so much magic to do, like let it do it. And yeah, you don't want
to override that anyway. You don't have to deal with like passing all the arguments.
Yeah. It's, you know, runs Python instead of maybe C, all these things. Right. So post
init would exist if you have more complex constraints, right?
Currently that's one reason to use it. We currently don't support custom validation
functions. There's no dot validate decorator, various frameworks, different ways of defining
these. We, we have some constraints that are built in. You can constrain, you know, if
the number to be greater than some value, but there's no way to specify custom constraints
currently. It's on the roadmap. It's the thing we want to add. Post init's a way to hack
around that. So right now you're looking at the screen, you have a post init defined and
you're checking if low is greater than high, raise an error. And that'll bubble up through
decodes and, you know, raise an isuser facing validation error. In the long run, we'd like
that to be done a little bit more field-based, similar to coming from other frameworks.
It is tricky though, because you know, the validation goes onto one field or the other.
You don't have like composite validators necessarily. Right. And so there's totally valid values
of this low, but it long, whatever it is, it has to be lower than high. Right. But how
do you express that relationship? So I think this is awesome. Other areas where, you know,
it could be interesting is like under some circumstances, maybe you've got to compute,
I don't know, compute some field also that's in there. That's not set. I don't know. There's,
there's some good options in here. I like it a lot. Yeah. I guess the errors just come
out as just straight out of like something went wrong with under post init, right. Rather
than field low has this problem.
It's a little harder to relate an error being raised to a specific field if you raise it
in the post init. Yeah. Also, since you're looking at this and I'm proud that I got this
to work, the post errors raised in post init use chained exceptions. So you can see a little
bit of the cause of where it comes from and getting those to work at the Python C API
is completely undocumented and a little tricky to figure out. A lot of reading how the interpreter
does it and making the right, you know, 12 incantations to get them to bubble up. Right.
Yeah. I do not envy you working on this struct, lower this base class, but that'd be, that's
where part of the magic is. Right. And that's why I wanted to dive into this because I think
it's, it behaves like Python classes, but it has this, these really special features
that we don't normally get, right. Like low memory usage, high performance, accessing
the fields. Is that any quicker or is it like standard struct level of quick?
Attribute access and settings should be the same as any other class. Things that are faster
are init, repper, not that that should matter. If you're looking for a high performance repper,
that's, you're doing it wrong. Seems like you're doing something wrong. Equality checks,
comparisons. So sorting, you know, less than greater than, I think that's it. Everything
else should be about the same.
So field ordering, you talked about like evolution over time. Does it, does this matter?
Field ordering is mostly defining how, what happens if you do subclasses and stuff. This
whole section is, if you're not subclassing, shouldn't hopefully be relevant to you. We
match how data class handles things for ordering.
Okay. So I could have my user, but I could have a super user that derives from my user
that derives from struct and things will still hang together.
And so figuring out how all the fields order out through that subclassing, this doc is
about.
Another type typing system thing you can do a lot is have explicitly claim something
as a class variable. You know, Python is weird about its classes and what makes a variable
that's associated with a class and or not. Right. So with these type of classes, you
would say like class example, colon, and then you have X colon int. Right. And that appears
will appear on the static type, like example dot X, but it also imbues each object with
its own copy of that X. Right. Which is like a little bit, is it a static thing or part
of the type or is it not? It's kind of funky, but you also can say that explicitly from
the typing, you say this is a class variable. What happens then? Right.
So standard attributes exist on the instances where a class var exists on the class itself.
Class vars are accessible on an instance, but the actual data is stored on the class.
So you're not having an extra copy.
I see. So if there's some kind of singleton type of thing or just one of them. Yeah.
Yeah. It has to do with how Python does attribute resolution where it'll check on the instance
and then on the type. And also there's descriptors in there, you know, somewhere.
Interesting. Okay. Like other things, I suppose it's pretty straightforward that you take
these types and you use them to validate them. But one of the big differences with message
spec dot struct versus pydantic dot base model and others is the validation doesn't happen
all the time. It just happens on encode decode. Right. Like you could call the constructor
and pass in bad data or like it just doesn't pay attention. Right. Yeah. Why is it like
that?
So this is one of the reasons I wrote my own thing rather than building off of something
existing like pydantic. Side tangent here just to add history context here. Message
spec was started about three years ago, the JSON and it kind of fell into its full model
about two years ago. So this has existed for around two years. Yeah. We're pre the pydantic
degree. Right. Anyway, the reason I wanted all of this was when you have your own code,
where bugs can come up are bugs in your own code. I've typed something wrong. I've made
a mistake and I want that to be checked or it can be user data is coming in or, you know,
maybe it's distributed system and it's still my own code. It's just a file or database.
Yeah. Whatever. Yeah. We have many mechanisms of testing our own code. You can write tests.
You have static analysis tools like my py, pywrite or checking. It's a lot easier for
me to validate that a function I wrote is correct. There are other tools I believe then
we should lean on rather than runtime validation in those cases. But when we're reading an
external data, whether it's coming over the wire or coming from a file, coming from user
input in some way, we do need to validate because the user could have passed us something
that doesn't match our constraints. Yeah. As soon as you start a trusting user input,
you're in for a bad time. We don't want to arbitrarily be trusting. We do validate on
JSON decoding without a master pack decoding. We also have a couple of functions for doing
in memory conversions. So there's msgspec convert msgspec to built-ins for
going the other way. So that's for doing conversion of runtime data that you got from some rather
than a specific format. Yeah. Because if you're calling this constructor and passing the wrong
data, my py should check that. Pycharm should check that. Maybe rough would catch it. I'm
not sure, but like there's a bunch of tools. Yeah. Rough doesn't have a type checker yet.
Yeah. TBD on that. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Being able to check these statically, it means that
we don't have to pay the cost every time we're running, which I don't think we should. That's
extra runtime performance that we don't need to be spending. Yeah. Definitely. Check it
on the boundaries, right? Check it where it comes into the system and then should be good.
The other reason I was against adding runtime validation to these trucks is I want all types
to be on equal footing. And so if I am creating a list, the list isn't going to be doing any
validation because it's, you know, the Python built in. Same with data classes, same with
adders, types, you know, whatever. And so only doing a validation when you construct
some object type that's from a built in that I've defined or like a type I've defined doesn't
give parity across all types and might give a user, you know, misconceptions about when
something is validated and when they can be sure it's correct versus when it hasn't.
Yeah. Have you seen bear type? I have. Yeah. Bear type's a pretty interesting option. If
people really want runtime validation, they could, you know, go in and throw bear type
onto their system and let it do its thing. Even if you're not doing it, you should read
the docs just for the sheer joy that these docs are. Oh, they are pretty glorious. Yeah,
I'll do it. You got it. This guy, they bearing the weight a little down here, but they described
himself as bear type brings rust and C++ inspired zero cost abstractions into the lawless world
of the dynamically typed Python by enforcing type safety at the granular level of functions
and methods against type hints standardized by the Python community of O order one non
amortized worst case time with negligible constant factors. Oh my gosh. So much fun,
right? They're just joking around here, but it's a pretty cool library. If you want runtime
type checking pretty fast. Okay. Interesting. You talked about the pattern matching. I'll
come back to that. One thing I want to talk about, well, okay. Frozen, frozen instances.
This comes from data classes without the instances being frozen. The structs are mutable. Yeah.
I can like get one changes value, serialize it back out, things like that. But frozen,
I suppose means what you would expect, right? Yeah. Frozen is the same meaning as a data
classic. How deep does frozen go? So for example, is it frozen all the way down? So in the previous
example from itamar, it had like the top level class and then like other structs that were
nested in there. Like if I say the top level is frozen to the nested ones themselves become
frozen? No. So frozen applies to the type. So if you define a type as frozen, that means
you can't change values that are set as attributes on that type, but you can still change things
that are inside it. So if a frozen class contains a list, you can still append stuff to the
list. There's no way to get around that except if we were to do some deep, deep, deep magic,
which we shouldn't. It would definitely slow it down if you had to go through and like
re create frozen lists every time you saw a list and stuff like that. Yeah. Okay. And
then there's one about garbage collection in here. Yeah. Which is pretty interesting.
There we go. Disabling garbage collection. This is under the advanced category. Warning
box around this that tells you not to. What could go wrong? Come on. Part of this was
experimenting with the DAS distributed scheduler, which is a unique application, I think, for
people that are writing web stuff in that all of its data is kept in memory. There's
no backing database that's external. And so it is as fast to respond as, you know, the
bits of in-memory computation that needs to do before it sends out a new task to a worker.
So in this case, their serialization performance matters. But also it's got a lot of in-memory
compute. You know, it's a dicts of types of, you know, lots of chaining down. The way the
CPython garbage collector works is that these large dictionaries could add GC overhead.
Every time a GC thing happens, it has to scan the entire dictionary.
Any container thing could contain another. And once you do that, there could be a cycle.
And then for very large graphs, GC pauses could become noticeable. Yes. This is an experiment
and seeing ways around that because we've done some deep magic with how structs work.
We can disable GC for subclasses, user-defined types, which CPython does not expose normally
and really isn't something you probably want to be doing in most cases. But if you do,
you get a couple benefits. The types are smaller. Every instance needs to include some extra
state for tracking GC. I believe on recent builds, it's 16 bytes. So it's two pointers.
So that's, you know, you're shaving 16 bytes print.
That's non-trivial. Yeah. If you got a huge list of them, that could be a lot.
And two, they don't, they're not traced. And so if you have a lot of them, that's a
reducing reduction in tracing overhead. Every time a GC pass happens.
GC puts more overhead on, on, on top of stuff than you would think. So I did some crazy
GC stuff over at talk Python and training of my courses. You go to slash sitemap.xml.
I don't know how many entries are in the sitemap, but there are 30,000 lines of sitemap, like
many, many, many, many, many thousands of URLs have to come back with details just to
generate that page in one request with the default Python settings in Python 3.10. I
think it was, it was doing 77 garbage collections while generating this page. That's not ideal.
I switched it to just change or tweak how frequently the GC runs. So like every 70,000,
no, every 50,000 allocations instead of every 700 and the site runs 20% faster now and uses
the same amount of memory. Right. And so this is not exactly what you're talking about here,
but it's in the, it plays in the same space as like you can dramatically change the things
that are triggering this and dramatically change the performance potentially. The caveat
is you better not have cycles.
Yeah. So the, the other thing with these is, as you pointed out is the indicator of when
a GC pass happens has to do with how many GC aware types have been allocated. And so
if you mark a type is not a GC type, then the counter is an increment. You're not paying
that cost.
So if you're going to allocate all the integers you want all day long, it'll never affect
the GC. But if you start allocating classes, dictionaries, tuples, et cetera, that is like,
well, those could contain cycles. You have 700 more than you've deallocated since last
time. I'm going to go check it.
One place this comes up is if you have say a really, really large JSON file because any
deserialization is in early in allocation, heavy workload, which means that you can have
a GC pause happen, you know, several times during it because you've allocated, you know,
that many types. Turning off GC for these types lets you avoid those GC pauses, which
gives you actual runtime benefits. A different way of doing this that is less insane is to
just disable GC during the decode. Do a, you know, GC disable, JSON decode, GC enable,
and you only do a GC pass once, especially because JSON as a tree-like structure can
never create cycles. You're not going to be having an issue there.
But you're probably allocating a lot of different things that are container types. And so it
looks to the GC like, oh, this is some really sketchy stuff. We better get on the game here.
But you know, as you said, there's no cycles in JSON. So there's a lot of scenarios like
that, like database queries. You know, I got a thousand records back from a table. They're
all some kind of container. So minimum one GC happens just to read back that data, but
you know, there's no cycles. So why is the GC happening? Right. You can kind of control
that a little bit, or you just turn the number up to 50,000 like I did. It still happens,
but less, a lot less. Yeah. So this is pretty interesting though, that you just set GC equals
false. Where do you set this? Is this like in the derived bit or?
It's part of the class definition. So we make use of class definition keyword arguments.
So it goes after the struct type in the subclass. You do, you know, my class, open a breath
of sea, struct, comma, GC equals false, close comma, colon, rest of the class.
Yeah. That's where I thought, but it is a little funky. I mean, it kind of highlights
the meta class action going on there. Right. What else should people know about these structs?
They're fast and they can be used for not just a serialization. So if you are just writing
a program and you happen to have msgspec on your system, it should be faster to use
them than data classes. Whether that matters is of course, application dependent, but they're
like generally a good idea. They happen to live in this serialization library, but that's
just because that's where I wrote them. Yeah. It's where they, in a future world, we might
split them out into a sub package. Yeah. Fast struct, Pippin's all fast struct.
Who knows? He had to be named. So better than data classes. I mean, they have the capabilities
of data classes, so that's cool, but better than straight up regular classes, like bare
classes, you know, class, colon, name.
Are opinionated a little bit. They're how I think people probably should be writing
classes and they're opinionated in a way that means that you can't write them in ways that
I don't want you to. So the way a struct works is you define attributes on it using type
annotations and we generate a fast init method for you. We don't let you write your own init.
In the subclass, you can't override init. The generated one is the one you get. That
means that like if you're trying to create an instance from something that isn't those
field names, you can't do that. You need to use a new class method for writing those.
I believe this is how people, at least on projects I work on, generally use classes.
So I think it's a fine limitation, but it is putting some guardrails around how the
arbitrariness of how you can define a Python class. You could have a, you know, a handwritten
class that has two attributes, X and Y, and your init takes, you know, parameters A and
B.
Sure. Or maybe it just takes X and it always defaults Y unless you go and change it after
or whatever. Right. I guess you could do sort of do that with default values, right? But
you couldn't prohibit it from being passed in. I'm feeling some factory classes.
The Adders docs have a whole, whole page telling people about why this pattern is, is better
and nudging them to do this. So this isn't a new idea.
Yeah. Go, go check out Adders and see what they're saying as well. Huh? There's probably
a debate in the issues somewhere on GitHub. There always is a debate. Yeah. Let's see.
Let's go get a bunch of stuff up here. I want to talk about, I guess really quickly, since
there's a lot of like C native platform stuff, right? This is available on, you know, pip
install message, msgspec. We're getting the wheel. It seemed like it worked fine on
my M2 MacBook Air. Like what are the platforms that I get a wheel that don't have to worry
about compiling?
So we use CI build wheel for building everything. And I believe I've disabled some of the platforms.
The ones that are disabled are mostly disabled because CI takes time and you need to minimize
them, but everything common should exist, including Raspberry Pi and various ARM builds.
Excellent. Okay. Yeah. It seemed like it worked just fine. I didn't really know that it was
like doing a lot of native code stuff, but it seems like it. And also available on Conda,
Conda Forge. So that's cool. If you Conda, you can also just Conda install it. I kind
of promised talking about the benchmarks a little bit, didn't I? So benchmarks are always.
If you click on the graph on the bottom, it'll get, bring you to it.
Yeah. They're always, always rife with like, that's not my benchmark. I'm doing it different,
you know, but give us a sense of just, it says fast italicies leaning forward. Give
us a sense of like, where does this land? Is it, you know, 20% faster or is it a lot
better?
Yeah. So as you said, benchmarks are a problem. The top of this benchmark docs has a whole
argument against believing them and telling you to run your own. So take the grain of
salt. I started benchmarking this mostly just to know how we stacked up. It's important
if you're making changes to know if you're getting slower, it's also important to know
what the actual trade-offs of your library are. All software engineering is trade-offs.
So msgspec is generally fast. The JSON parser in it is one of the fastest in Python
or the fastest, depending on what your message structure is and how you're invoking it. It
at least is on par with, or JSON, which is generally what people consider to be the fast
parser.
Right. That's, that's where they go when they want fast. Yeah.
So if you are specifying types, so if you, you know, add in a type annotation to a JSON
decode call with message spec, even if you're decoding the whole message, you're not doing
a subset. We're about two X faster than our JSON. You actually get a speed up by defining
your types because struct types are so efficient to allocate versus a deck.
That's kind of the opposite of what you might expect, right?
It seems like we're doing more work, but we're actually able to do less because we can take
some more, you know, efficient fast paths.
And then a thousand objects with validation compared to, yeah, Mesher, Merle, C Adders,
Pydantic and so on. Probably the last one.
This was a grab bag of various validation libraries that seemed popular. Mesher Merle
is the one that dbt uses. I think they're the primary consumer of that. Catters is for
Adders. Pydantic is, you know, ubiquitous. This right here in this, this benchmark graph
we're looking at is against Pydantic V1. I have not had a chance to update our benchmarks
to go against V2. There's a separate gist somewhere that is, got some numbers there.
The standard number they throw out is like 22 times faster. So it still puts you multiples
faster.
In that benchmark, we're averaging 10 to 20 X faster than Pydantic V2. In numbers I run
against V1, we're about 80 to 150 X faster. So it really is structure dependent.
Yeah, sure. You have one field or do you have a whole bunch of stuff?
Yeah, exactly. And what types of fields? To be getting more into the weeds here, JSON
parsing is not easy. Message pack parsing is like the form that was designed for computers
to handle it. It's, you know,
Seven bytes in there is an integer here.
Yeah. Okay. Where, where JSON is human readable and parsing strings into stuff is slow.
Right. The flexibility equals slowness. Yeah.
Our string parsing routines in, in msgspec are faster than the ones used by or JSON.
Our integer parsing routines are slower, but there's a different trade off there.
Interesting. Okay. Yeah. I think this is just seems so neat. There's so much flexibility,
right? With all the different formats and the restrictions on the class, they exist,
but they're unstruck, but they're, they're not insane. Right? I mean, you build a proper,
proper OOP type of things. You don't need super crazy hierarchies. Like that's where
you get in trouble with that stuff anyway. So don't do it. I guess we don't have much
time left. One thing I think we could talk about a bit, maybe it would be, if I find
it, the extensions. Just maybe talk about parsing stuff that are, is kind of unknown.
This is pretty interesting.
So the way we allow extension currently, this is, there's an intention to change this and
expand it, but currently extending, adding new types is done via a number of different
hooks that are called when a new type is encountered. So custom user defined type of some form.
I liked doing this rather than adding it into the annotation, because if I have a new type,
I want it to exist probably everywhere. And I don't want to have to keep adding in and
use the serializer and deserializer and as part of the type annotations. So to define
a new type that you want to encode, you can add an encode hook, which takes in the instance
and returns something that msgspec knows how to handle. This is similar to, if you're
coming from standard library JSON, there's a default callback. It's the same. We renamed
it to be a little better name in my mind, but it's the same thing.
Right. So your example here is taking a complex number, but storing it as a tuple of real
and imaginary numbers, but then pulling it back into a proper complex number object.
Super straightforward. Yeah. But makes it possible. Yeah. Yeah. That's really cool.
So people can apply this and this, I guess, would, didn't really matter on the output
destination, does it? Your job is here is to take a type that's not serializable to
one that is, and then whether that goes to a message, a message pack or JSON or whatever,
it's kind of not your problem.
Yeah. And then the decode hook is the inverse. You get a bunch of stuff that is, you know,
core types and strings, whatever, and you compose them up into your new custom type.
Jim, I think we're getting about out of time here, but I just want to point out, like if
people hit the user guide, there's a lot of cool stuff here and there's a whole performance
tips section that people can check out. You know, if we had more time, maybe we'd go into
them, but like, for example, you can call msgspec dot JSON dot encode, or you can
create an encoder and say the type and stuff, and then reuse that, right? Those, those kinds
of things. Yeah.
There's another method that is, again, a terrible internal hack for reusing buffers. So you
don't have to keep allocating byte buffers every message. You can allocate a byte array
once and use it for everything. Save some memory.
Let me ask Ellie's got a question. I'm going to read some words that don't mean anything
to me, but they've made to you. How does the performance of message pack plus message spec
with the array-like equals true optimization compared to flat buffers?
So by default objects, so struct types, data classes, whatever, encode as objects in the
stream. So a JSON object has keys and values, right? If you have a point with fields X and
Y, it's got X and Y, you know, one, two. We have an array-like optimization, which lets
you drop the field names. And so that would instead encode as an array of, you know, one
comma two, dropping the X and Y reduces the message size on the wire. If the other side
knows what the structure is, it can, you know, pull that back up into a type.
In terms of message pack as a format, plus with the array-like optimization, the output
size should be approximately the same as you would expect it to come out of flat buffers.
The Python flat buffers library is not efficient for creating objects from the binary. So it's
going to be a lot faster to pull it in. Obviously, this is then a very custom format. You're
doing a weird thing. And so compatibility with other ecosystems will be slower or not
slower necessarily, but you'll have to write them yourself. Not everything knows how to
read message pack.
More brittle potentially.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah.
But for Python, talking to Python, that's probably the fastest way to go between processes.
And probably a lot faster than JSON or YAML or something like that.
Okay. Excellent. I guess, you know, there's many more things to discuss, but we're going
to leave it here. Thanks for being on the show. Final call to action. People want to
get started with message back. Are you accepting PRs if they want to contribute and what's,
what do you tell them?
First, I encourage people to try it out. I am available, you know, to answer questions
on GitHub and stuff. It is obviously a hobby project. So, you know, if the, the usage bandwidth
increases significantly, we'll have to get some more maintainers on and hopefully we
can make this more maintainable over time.
But once the sponsor funds exceed a 10,000, 20, 30,000 a month, like it'll revalue your,
no, just kidding.
Sure. Sure. But yeah, please try it out. Things work should be hopefully faster than what
you're currently using and hopefully intuitive to use. We've done a lot of work to make sure
the API is friendly.
Yeah. It looks pretty easy to get started with. The docs are really good.
Oh, thank you.
Congrats on the cool project. Thanks for taking the time to come on the show and tell everyone
about it.
Thanks.
Yeah. See you later.
Bye.
This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me. Thank you to our sponsors. Be sure
to check out what they're offering. It really helps support the show. This episode is sponsored
by Posit Connect from the makers of Shiny. Publish, share and deploy all of your data
projects that you're creating using Python. Streamlit, Dash, Shiny, Bokeh, FastAPI, Flask,
Quatro, Reports, Dashboards and APIs. Posit Connect supports all of them. Try Posit Connect
for free by going to talkpython.fm/posit. P-O-S-I-T.
Want to level up your Python? We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video courses
over at Talk Python. Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced topics like
memory and async. And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight. Check it out
for yourself at training.talkpython.fm. Be sure to subscribe to the show. Open your favorite
podcast app and search for Python. We should be right at the top. You can also find the
iTunes feed at /iTunes, the Google Play feed at /play, and the direct RSS feed at /rss
on talkpython.fm. We're live streaming most of our recordings these days. If you want
to be part of the show and have your comments featured on the air, be sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube. This is your host, Michael Kennedy. Thanks
so much for listening. I really appreciate it. Now get out there and write some Python
code.
[MUSIC]
[END]
[BLANK_AUDIO]